welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to you okay so if you've been
following the channel since day one then
you'll know that I actually started this
up as a Batman graphic novel review
channel and I've been pretty obsessed
with the character since my grandma gave
me a comic as three with the Dark
Knight's splashed across the front page
hell I was even one of the three people
actually like Batman V Superman
so naturally I like I'm sure many have
been pretty glued to the whole back and
forth casting news about who could play
the new caped crusader well it looks
like we finally have confirmation that
Robert Patterson will replace Ben
Affleck as the titular character in the
upcoming Matt Reeves film Batman variety
have reported that it's between him and
Nicholas Hoult
with Pattinson edging it out over the
other actor of Deadpool Fame now as
always whenever someone's cast as the
character there's a huge ordeal about it
over the Internet with many kind of
shouting down the choice and stating how
bad it will be even my wife and mates
messaged me this morning said he's gonna
suck but I think he may just be okay we
saw this originally with Michael Keaton
when he was put in the role and
Patterson is no different now does he
jump out as the perfect casting to me no
not really but I've been wrong before
and initially I hated news on Affleck
but once he was in the role I thought he
was the most accurate representation
that we've ever had on screen still this
is going to be a controversial one with
Patterson not really having done
anything major since the Twilight series
that birth his career I think if he
bucks up he definitely has the look and
he's already used to playing a solitary
vampire which is pretty similar to
Batman when you think about it I think
Hollywood is just dropping this before
they confirm the contract double check
they are doing the right thing but for
me I just want them to get the project
off the ground and actually make this
movie Batman is still scheduled for its
June 25th 2021 release so hopefully this
is fully confirmed in the next couple of
hours or days at the most
and we can get the ball rolling with
saving the DC Universe whatever it takes
sorry that's a wrong franchise obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
news and if you think it's a good choice
in art comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of Kevin Feige 's ask me
anything would you be linked at the end
I also run a website where I've reviewed
over 200 Batman graphic novels I'm kind
of working my way through them one by
one in chronological order so I'll leave
a link to that in the description below
if you want to read more of my in-depth
thoughts on Batman and the comics that
you should check out this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe thanks again
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]